how do we reconcile the possession of the
holy spirit and speaking in tongues speaking
in tongues let me pray again father tongues
are such a misunderstood subject help me to
make it clear and simple in jesus name i pray
amen there are some people is widely believed
in christianities particularly evangelical
christianity if you do not speak in tongues
you're not born again that is a teaching that has
no not one molecule of origin in the word of god
towns is a gift that came to prominence in acts
chapter 2 and it was made necessary because they
came to celebrate pentecost and pentecost
was honored three gifts that all jewish men
had to celebrate at jerusalem so it's not just the
feast the place is also important they had to come
people say i don't have to go to church yes you
should go this place is also important they had
to go to jerusalem to celebrate three feasts now
the the jews have been scattered far and wide the
roman empire the persian empire the gregion empire
and so they began to speak different languages so
they all came together not fully understanding
each other now here was an opportunity to preach
the gospel so that they can take the gospel back
to those far-flung corners of the empire of the
romans and so god said jesus actually sent the
gifts of towns through the spirit and the but
if you read acts chapter 2 for about verse 8 we
have the parthians the medes the cappadocia all
the various nations from eight about 11 telling
us that there were literal languages people
understood and the people confessed in verses 7
8 we are hearing them in the language where when
we were born it was just not noise as is the
case in many churches on every sunday morning
you ask those people what did he just say nobody
knows you ask the same person what did you say the
person doesn't know it is unintelligible noise
now let me say as i answer the spirit and gifts
a person in private interaction with god may say
anything he or she likes god may do that no one
understands no one is present it is a prison
affair but if you read first corinthians 14
carefully any public service where tongues
are yours everyone must understand because
the purpose of the gift is for the edification of
the church of god and for there to be edification
they must be understanding and by the way if you
read first corinthians 14 from verse 28 to 29 you
will discover that the bible says where there is
no interpretation the people ought to keep quiet
there should be no speaking in tongues publicly
where there is no interpretation and so the role
of the spirit and tongues this tongues is just
one of several gifts and we read them in first
corinthians 12 8 to 10 28 to 30 we find them in
romans 12 6 and 8 and ephesians chapter 4 verse
11. all those tongues are under the control of the
spirit of god and are given as the spirit chooses
to give them so every converted person does not
have to speak in tongues there is no record of
jesus speaking in tongues even though i'm sure he
could the gifts are given for if you read first
corinthians 12 8 the bible says 12 verse 8 for the
one is given by the spirit the gift of wisdom to
another the gift of knowledge by the same spirit
and so we have two people with two different gifts
that's how gifts are given i'm trying to cover
a lot in this question because it's so important
not all persons have the gift of tongues it is
a tremendous error you find in these tongues
speaking churches and i don't want to speak
discouragingly about them but i can't find another
way to say it every sunday tang tang song no
one understands and so the languages of the gift
of tongues are languages that can be understood
whenever tongues is used publicly let me stress
if it is used publicly the bible says there
must be interpretation the bible also said
first corinthians 14 verse 28 to 30 that
only one person must speak at the time
it amazes me how the bible is so clear and people
do whatever they want one person at a time or the
mind who says no more than two or three she'll
speak in tongues no more than two or three
not an entire church if i sound like i'm raging
or raving it's because i do not understand how
the bible can be so clear and people choose
to do whatever they like let me review
the tongues in the bible are legitimate tongues
that people understood and this is the context in
which tongues are introduced in the new testament
acts chapter 8 acts chapter 2 from verse 8 to 11.
first corinthians 14 only two or three shall speak
and one at a time the bible also says in that
passage if the person's if someone sitting who has
to give has a special revelation the one speaking
must have to sit down it's very organized that's
why in that very same chapter the bible says
let all things be done decently and in order
because everyone back then was trying to speak
in towns and that's what we see because god is not
the author of confusion what paul is saying all
this noisy speaking in tongue is confusion let me
be very harsh but i have to be if god is not the
author of confusion and that kind of worship is
confusion who is the author of that it is not god
it can only be one of the person the fact that
it happens in the church does not make it right
it has to be biblical and so tongues is a gift
given to the church to fill a need but with google
translate and all the resources we have who needs
the gifts of tongues if god sees there's a need in
some remote area somewhere he will give it but in
our setting where we have all these resources we
don't need the gift of talent god does not display
his power because he has nothing else to do
it has to be connected with his glory and fill
a specific need all right enough of that amen
and uh the verse i want to highlight upon that to
read it in full is first corinthians 14 verses 33
as you mentioned for god is not the author of
confusion but of peace as in all churches the city
i had that same same instance a lady was
praying for me she was a pastor and then
actually was praying she started seeing these
words and i was like what is she saying yes yes
and i said what's the point of saying these words
if i can't understand and the holy spirit cannot
convict me with whatever she's saying in that word
that's right and so that's what we see the devil
wants you you say these words that people will not
understand so the holy spirit cannot convict them
on that particular segment of their their sermon
right um but we have to pray for those people
we have to pray for those people including
each one of us and so the final last question
elder steeped in tongues on sunday don't speak
this on tuesday oh well if you have a gift
you can use that gift seven days a week it's a
gift and once you have the gift it's not taken
away how come the gift can only be expressed on
sunday it makes no sense and only between 11 and
1 it makes no sense at all makes no sense all i
hear is just pride right and hold closer to god